[Musik]
herzlich willkommen im Brunn am Gebirge
der Ort wo die heeresbekleidungsanstalt
bereits seit 110 Jahren
Ausrüstungsgegenstände und
Bekleidungsgegenstände für das
österreichische Bundesheer entwickelt
die Qualitätssicherung sicherstellt und
die Verteilung an die Soldaten
durchführt mein Name ist amtsrecht der
Markus Waldner ich bin der Leiter der
heeresbekleidungsanstalt und lade euch
heute ein mit mir gemeinsam durch unsere
Räumlichkeiten zu gehen und zu sehen wie
wir entwickeln wie funktioniert die
Qualitätssicherung und wie schaut die
Verteilung an die Soldaten des
österreichischen Bundesheeres aus
hier und die erste Station die
Entwicklungsabteilung hier ist die
Geburtsstunde aller ausrüstungs-
und Ausrüstungsgegenstände angepasst und
am Ende wird hier ein schnittlage Bild
erstellt das auch als Grundlage dient
für die Firmen um die Produktionen die
Massenproduktion für das österreichische
Bundesheer durchführen zu können
das Herzstück unserer Prototypen und
Musterfertigung ist der laserkarte die
Schnitte aus der schnittzeichenanlage
werden hier digital übertragen und
werden durch den laser cutter mit dieser
Maschine ausgeschnitten wenn die
ausgeschnittenen Teile fertig sind
kommen sie direkt in die Schneiderei und
werden dort zusammengenäht und der
Prototyp oder das Muster entstehen wir
sind jetzt hier in der
ausrüstungswerkstätte hier werden die
Gegenstände die Schnittmuster die der
laser cutter zugeschnitten hat zu einem
Ausrüstungsgegenstand gefertigt wir
sehen hier den Zuschnitt aus dem laser
cutter der
teilkonfektioniert mit flauschbändern
und Klettbändern versehen ist hier das
fertige Teil und hier sehen wir wo
dieser Teil dann in der Rüstung verbaut
werden wir sind jetzt hier im
Musterlager der Prototyp ist fertig
warum machen wir Prototypen wir bauen
Prototypen und für unsere Soldaten für
Ihre Aufträge das bestmögliche was es am
Markt der aus der Industrie und an Ideen
von anderen Armeen gibt und diese
stellen wir zusammen und die Bedürfnisse
unserer Soldaten sicherzustellen
wir sind jetzt an der zweiten Station
den textiltechnisch und chemischen
Prüfzentren nachdem die Industrie den
Prototypen das angebotsmustern
nachgebaut hat hielt es jetzt nun dieses
zu überprüfen ob es bis in die Phase
übereinstimmt hier wird jedes
bekleidungs- und Ausrüstungsstück bis in
die Faser zerlegt und sämtliche
Prüfungen durchgeführt ob es der
Qualität entspricht wir sind jetzt hier
im physikalischen Prüfraum hier wird die
Qualität der Produkte die die Firmen uns
vorlegen sei es bei der beim Angebot
aber auch bei der Einlieferung überprüft
ob Sie unseren Vorgaben entsprechen wir
haben hier zum Beispiel den martin-test
ein scheuertest wo zwei Textilien so
lange aneinander gescheuert werden bis
eine pillenbildung oder Löcher entstehen
die Zeit unter die Anzahl der
Steuervorgänge wird gemessen und das ist
ein Mast ein Maß für die Qualität des
Stoffes hier an der zugprüfmaschine ist
ein Turnschuhe eingespannt wo einerseits
an der Sohle und andererseits am Touren
schon selbst gezogen wird bis es
auseinander reißt und die Kraft die dazu
notwendig ist wird gemessen diese muss
unseren Vorgaben entsprechen damit wir
dieses Produkt als qualitätsvolles
Produkt für unsere Soldaten übernehmen
was ist hier passiert hier ein paar
Socken einmal gewaschen und hier sieht
man ganz eindeutig die Firma hat sich
die Ausrüstung für die Waschbarkeit der
Wolle erspart und dies zu überprüfen
haben wir hier unseren Waschraum mit
drei Waschmaschinen einer
industriewaschmaschine enorm
Waschmaschine und auch eine
Haushaltswaschmaschine weil die Soldaten
waschen auch ganz normal daheim in ihre
eigenen Umgebung
hier wird auch künstlich gealtert es
werden 10 bis 20 Waschgänge für ein
Bekleidungsstück durchgeführt und man
ist auch das Ausbluten also sprich das
Auswaschen der Farben hier wird auch
überprüft
nach dem Auswaschen der Farben wird auch
noch zusätzlich die infrareemission
überprüft das ist die Sichtbarkeit bei
Infrarotlicht damit unsere Soldaten auch
nach 50 Mal waschen der Uniform und
danach den infrarotgeräten nicht weiß
leuchten ich da vorstellen unser Labor
Mitarbeiter money money dazu
um die Wasserdichtheit unserer
nässeschutzbekleidung zu überprüfen
meine trägt unter der nächste
Schutzbekleidung ein Sensor Hemd und das
Sehnsucht ist mit dem Computer verbunden
und Mist die Feuchtigkeit die wenn die
Dusche läuft durch die Begleitung
durchgeht wenn irgendwelche qualitativen
Schwächen da werden
hier sind wir gerade mitten in einer
Prüfung drinnen der Kampfstiefel der
neue im beige steht hier drinnen und
wird eine Million Schritt machen und
zwar dem eine Million Schritte ist
notwendig damit wir feststellen können
festhalten können wie hoch dieser
geröllstreifen sein darf damit er wenn
er vorne abbiegt beim Gehen nicht
aufreißt und keine keine Risse bekommen
nach Menge der für uns die nächste
Schutzbekleidung prüft und im Regen
steht haben wir semi der dafür uns
durchs Feuer geht semi steht in einer
brandkammer und hier wird schwer im
flammbares Außenmaterial von mit drei
Bunsenbrenner von außen beflämmt um
Ihnen zu messen wie wirkt sich das auf
den Soldaten und die Soldaten selbst aus
bzw wie beeinflusst unter Bekleidung den
schweren Flammen waren Schutz des
Soldaten und des Soldaten
hier zum Beispiel was semi alles
aushalten muss schwer im flammbare
Produkte heißt nicht dass sie nicht
brennen sondern dass sie von selbst
wieder ausgehen und somit den Träger
schützen
man sieht der Stoff ist nicht in Flammen
aufgegangen und der Träger drunter wurde
geschützt allerdings diese
temperaturübergang auf den Körper den
können wir mit semitern genau messen wir
befinden uns hier jetzt in der
zerstörungsfreienprüfung hier werden die
Ausrüstungsgegenstände die uns die
Firmen als angebotsmuster als
vorproduktionsmuster oder als
Einlieferung vorlegen maßtechnisch
geprüft hier überprüfen wir die
schulänge die in den schullänge
beispielsweise die Verarbeitung der
Nähte das den optischen Zustand des
Leders der Schnallen und sonstigen
Gegenständen bzw das sollen zur
zerstörungsfreien Prüfung gehört auch
die Prüfung der Stoffes an sich wir
haben dazu stoffschaummaschinen wir
wenden das vor allem dann an und die
Qualität zu erhöhen bei besonderen
Stoffen mit besonderen Eigenschaften wie
zum Beispiel schweren flammbar hier wird
der Stoff zuerst eingeliefert wird hier
überprüft auf der stoffschaummaschine
auf Fehler oder Farbfehler und wenn wenn
der Stoff überprüft ist und entspricht
wird er dann den Konfektionär zur
Herstellung der Uniform oder der
Ausrüstung übergeben hier ein Beispiel
für einen sogenannten Verwurf ein
Gegenstand den jeder kennt der
Wollsocken im übrigen ist es der
Gegenstand der am längsten
gleichbleibend beim österreichischen
Bundesheer von Bekleidung eingesetzt ist
man sieht hier hier ist eine Laufmasche
aufgebrochen das heißt diese Socken
entsprechen nicht unseren Kriterien und
werden somit nicht angenommen und wenn
eine gewisse Stückzahl über Schritten
wird die in einer Norm festgelegt ist
bei einer Einlieferung dann wird die
Lieferung wieder zurückgeben dann kommt
es zu einer Nichtabnahme ich war mit
euch in der Station 1 der Entwicklung
ich war mit euch in der Station 2 das
zerstörenden und der zerstörungsfreien
Prüfung der Bekleidungsstücke und der
Ausrüstungsgegenstände hier befinden wir
uns im eingangslagerbereich
Wirtschaftsabteilung wo palettenweise
die Wahrheit durch die Industrie
angeliefert wird hier in meinem
Hintergrund der Damen zugleich die Jacke
zum Beispiel die hier auf die Annahme
die quantitative also das Zählen auf die
Abnahme die qualitative Überprüfung und
die Übernahme wartet im weiterer Folge
erfolgen die Aufträge durch die
Dispositionsabteilung zu Verteilung in
der Armee und zur Verteilung an die
österreichischen Soldaten
[Musik]